en directo a América actualizamos la
información económica por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge el precio del petróleo cayó a
niveles no vistos desde 2020 con esa
noticia abrimos Y es que el petróleo
llegó a la peor racha de pérdidas en más
de dos años con su tercera caída mensual
consecutiva El combustible se cotizó
este 31 de agosto por debajo de los 90
dólares el barril con los precios del
West Texas de Estados Unidos en 88,9
dólares el barril y el brent británico
en
96,49 dólares el barril lo que deja una
caída mensual de alrededor del 10%. los
precios del crudo se han visto afectados
principalmente por los temores de
recesión en los mercados con Europa
inmersa en una crisis energética las
estrictas medias de Cero covid en China
y varios bancos centrales del mundo
endureciendo sus políticas monetarias
para tratar de contener la elevada
inflación porque Europa y Estados Unidos
buscan definir un precio tope para el
petróleo Ruso y es que el grupo de los
países más ricos del mundo
como el g7 planea definir este viernes
el límite de los precios para la
principal fuente de ingresos de Rusia
los líderes occidentales restringirán
cuánto pueden pagar las refinerías y los
comerciantes de todo el mundo por el
crudo ruso en una acción conjunta para
seguir presionando a Rusia por la
invasión en Ucrania aparte del tope de
precio de la Casa Blanca también propuso
que se considere un bloqueo del
transporte del petróleo Ruso y en
palabras de la secretaría del tesoro de
Estados Unidos Janet yelem esta medida
Sí lograría su objetivo tras el poco
impacto de otras sanciones contra Rusia
escuchamos que decía yemen
tal como lo veo el tope de precios
promoverá nuestros dos objetivos clave
el primero por supuesto reducir los
ingresos que Putin necesita para
continuar librando su guerra de agresión
y el segundo es mantener un suministro
confiable de petróleo para el mercado
global y presionar a la baja el precio
de la energía para las personas en
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido y en todo
el mundo
sin embargo comerciantes y analistas
dudan que este tope de precio funcione
ya que Moscú ha encontrado otras
alternativas para la venta del crudo
Pues a pesar de que las exportaciones de
petróleo ruso en agosto llegaron a
niveles muy Bajos en junio el kremlin
encontró una forma de enviar los
barriles hacia sin el uso de barcos
occidentales esta decisión hizo que las
exportaciones en este mes aumentaran al
menos un 40% por encima del promedio del
año pasado Jorge y hay nuevos cortes de
gas de Rusia a Europa como lo tomaron
los países del viejo continente bueno es
que la rusa gas pron anunció que por
cuestiones de mantenimiento el
suministro energético hacia Europa ha
sido cortado y estaría así por tres días
Es decir hasta el próximo sábado
Alemania ha dicho que está lista para
afrontar la crisis energética pues ya
tiene el almacenamiento de sus plantas
por encima del 80% de países como
Bélgica y Grecia han seguido la senda de
España con la implementación de medidas
de ahorro energético de esta manera el
gobierno belga publicó el miércoles
ideas que incluyen recortes en el
consumo de energía de los edificios
públicos las restricciones de la
calefacción para los comercios a máximos
de 19 grados en la temporada de invierno
y la iluminación de las oficinas y
monumentos que se va a pagar a partir de
las 7 de la noche todas estas medidas se
discuten también si las luces en las
algunas carreteras de algunas ciudades
se deberían Apagar en determinadas horas
la media llega luego de que la oficina
estadística de la Unión Europea eurostad
dijera principio de este año que Bélgica
tenía la inflación energética más alta
del bloque
Jorge y vamos a México ahora porque el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
reconoció que necesita capital privado
para explotar las reservas de litio
bueno el litio o sea Hablamos del metal
más liviano conocido y según la Real
Sociedad de química de Reino Unido
cuenta con excelentes propiedades de
conducción de calor y electricidad que
han permitido la fabricación de baterías
celulares computadoras cámaras digitales
y hasta vehículos eléctricos México
Había nacionalizado la minería de litio
en abril y luego en agosto creó una
empresa pública que administraría gran
parte de las operaciones mineras de este
metal ahora el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador aseguró que la empresa
será público privada y empezará a
recibir apoyo de inversionistas
nacionales y extranjeros debido a que
según él necesita mucho capital para su
funcionamiento Jorge y nuestra cifra del
día
137,400 millones de dólares Esa es la
fortuna neta de gautan a Dani el tercer
hombre más rico del mundo según el
índice de multimillonarios de la agencia
number a Dani sería el primer asiático
en ingresar al top 3 de esta lista y
está por encima del informático Bill
Gates y tan solo lo superan Jeff bezos y
elon musk por Hurtado con la información
económica Muchas gracias seguimos con
más aquí en directo América